je suis écrasé la cas tant de projets ni
la critique de vanille l'île de la
réunion ça fait des dizaines de salons
qu'on fait maintenant toujours avec une
très grande envie est pressée de voir
nos clients ça fait deux ans les a pas
vu donc on sait que
[Musique]
avec impatience comme nom qui
s'impliquent pour 2022 bien sûr c'est
les gpéens c'est notre produit gp que
vous pouvez voir ici toute une gamme
on a reçu après dix années de démarches
donc maintenant c'est fait c'est notre
bannir les reconnue donc et c'est
valoriser au moins un touriste qui
viendra la réunion qui à chaque fois sa
vanille il saura que cissé labellisé gp
que ça a été produit et transforme et
habite dollar est un gage de qualité
pour lui alors on a bien sûr une gamme
bio ici le vinaigre à la vanille ont
fait à molines et bret pour déglacer
votre plat est là malgré elle par
exemple vous avez également la poudre de
vanille donc ça c'est pratique et
surtout ça évite le gaspillage puisque
souvent c'est pas quoi faire de la nuit
de vanille on a bien sûr du sucre à la
vanille mais là c'est du vrai ce cas la
vanille et non pas
de chimie qu'un tel qu'on peut acheter
en grande surface la frappe soir
sur une crème brûlée ça passe très bien
l'alliance de coiffer à votre rhum
arrangé notre propre rangé c'est la base
maintenant à vous de rajouter ensuite
des fruits de saison une gamme parc
national est leur esprit pape qui existe
aussi un ici en métropole là aussi on
n'a pas beaucoup de producteurs défaut
est à l'intérieur du parc national à la
réunion donc là ce sont des produits qui
sont cultivés c'est la vanille cultivés
à sainte rose est la seule à roches
volcaniques ont un ami qui a été
médaillé d'eau en 2019 ici au salon de
l'agriculture
c'est
la gamme qu'on appelle la vanille et là
le fait qu'elles sont cultivés sur de la
roche volcanique ça va fournir des
minéraux qui vont transformer légèrement
la roumanie 7 a apprécié le joli en 2010
voilà donc pas mal de produits dérivés
de l'ex très bien sûr que vous avez ici
l'extrait de vanille là aussi pratique
seule différence avec la poudre ce que
voudrait pas les petites graines noires
vous aurez pas le côté visuel ça c'est
bien pour faire un beau yaourts ou par
exemple pour vous aider à mieux utiliser
une avanie on a édité un petit livret de
recettes
on nous aurait tous de sucre et comme
tous aller puisque la vanille celui
également dans du sel